welcome back to 8701
in this chapter we will talk about
neutrinos and we'll start the discussion
with a
relatively simple introduction um how
does the neutrino look in
the standard model and how does it
interact um
we have discussed the neutrino already
quite a bit so this is
more or less a summary in the standard
model the neutrino is massless
it's a massless particle and it acts via
the weak interaction
so it interacts with w bosons and with z
bosons and specifically it does not
interact with photons or blue ones um
you know if you look at the lagrangian
or try to write down the current
uh we find that there is a charge guard
we have a w
and there's a neutral current via the z
boson
it's quite interesting to think about
those two currents a little bit more
so in case of a charged current um
we for example have an incoming neutrino
we can determine
the flavor the kind of neutrino we have
we are detecting the flavor of the
lepton
so if we for example identify an
electron
in this interaction then the initial in
the interaction the initial
neutrino was an electron neutrino while
for the neutral current
when we have um you know some sort of
interaction
happening we cannot identify directly
the neutrino
hence we cannot find the flavor of the
neutrino
you can just measure the sum of all
flavors of neutrinos in the
nutrient count on that story neutrinos
have three flavors they come in
electron flavor muon flavor or tau
flavor
neutrinos are left-handed anti-neutrinos
are right-handed
um so that's the story that's
how neutrinos are characterized in the
standard model
in the standard model we can in the
content
in in the framework we set up um we can
calculate cross-sections scattering
cross-sections
and here we are looking at you know
neutrino nuclear
nuclei scattering again we can split
this up
um in the charged current in neutral car
discussion
but they go very much in in parallel so
we have elastic scattering or in the
case of the charged current we talk
about
quasi-elastic scattering where we have
an incoming neutrino let's say a mu
neutrino
hitting a neutron producing a muon and a
proton it's called quasi elastic because
we do
not break up the target but we change
its
um it's it's kind so we change from a
neutron
to a proton in this case while for the
elastic scattering the neutron just
stays intact
we can also have nuclear resonant
production where we hit the nuclei and
then inside the nuclei
we produce a meson like a
neutral or charged pion and also that
possible in the
in the neutral current exchange and then
we have deep inelastic scattering
uh where we we hit a nuclei
a nucleon that hard that would start
breaking it up
and in this case you know we scatter off
the quark and we produce a new quark
in the charge current interaction in the
same quad
in the neutral carbon interaction um
so you know this is not different from
the stories we had before
the intriguing part about studying
neutrino scattering is that
we do know that we haven't we have
weak interactions being being the
dominant both being the process
while if we um use photons to interact
or we have electrons being intact and we
can have a mixture of weak
and weak and electromagnetic interaction
another important takeaway from this
slide is that when we calculate
cross-section we find that a linear
increase in the cross-section as a
function of the energy
so while cross-sections for neutrino are
small
at higher energy those cross sections
scale linearly
as we can discuss this for neutrino
scattering with
nuclei and nucleons you can also look at
neutrinos scattering with electrons
directly there's a lot of electrons in
the matter around us and when neutrinos
travel through this matter they can
interact with electrons too
and they can leave in the charged
current interaction
a muon and an electron neutrino and a
neutral current interaction
an electron in the mirror nitrogen
also here you see cross-section total
cross-section scale with s with the
energy
good that's the first first introduction
to neutrino physics we'll go into more
detail in the following
presentations